the next section uh is
the hasso's the
the previous uh suburbs
may seem a strange thing to say but uh
i class them more as uh precise and uh
can be rather stiff looking
the body's held in a sort of a rigid way
not on all of them of course but the the
hasso's i'd like to really say to you
this is where you need to let up and be
more flexible
not with the body you're following the
joe a lot more
there's more movement with the body more
flexibility with the body
and more adaptations can be made and
created
so i'd like to go into the first hasso
and different footwork
different thoughts that i've had about
household
i've mentioned on another film that
they say there's only one hasso but in
my opinion there's
definitely two and then you've got
variations
on those two
the standard one is you go to the middle
of the joe
and if you're a beginner and you see it
doing that you're not quite in the
middle you need to be the exact middle
so
when you open your hand it sits there
if it's slightly out and you open your
hand that will happen
it's rare that that happens
but you need to get used to that
you can put a piece of tape around here
or if you don't mind
writing on your joe scribe a line
even measure it if you want to get the
exact middle of the joe
scribe a line put a dot or something
on there you need to be in the middle of
the joe
so you need to test yourself
out
test yourself
to see
whether you're out or look okay
this is preciseness
to the middle of the joe flat hand check
it
flat hand check it
once you've got used to where the middle
is
like i say marking is a really good way
of doing it especially for beginners
and sometimes that's advanced people
stepping forward is the standard one
drop the end you're holding it but
you're also
allowing it the space
this is in the middle it doesn't want to
be this side it wants to be
that side of the body
this is no good they come to ski you
you've got to deflect it
now moving with the body middle
step forward tipping of the hips the
same as you do
when cutting with the ken so it's
the same as when cutting with the can
you tip the pelvis
then sweep it up and the feeling is to
go up high
hold it in this position this is the
hasso
and the feeling then is to settle into
this position
you turn the hand
it it tips like the eye of an
oar in a boat eye a rowing boat eye
goes forwards not out
but forwards tipping in that eye
it comes as you turn the body and the
foot
it comes together and lines up
you close the hand
and strike i always strike to parallel
but you can strike to
chest height if you wish doesn't matter
really about the height
this is uh what i do for basic
oh
my foot turns with the jar
and stroke like stroking
the horse's mane stroking your dog's
back
or your cat stroke it
up
strike
this is with stepping forward step back
as you slide down the jug
so
great
this is um
the points on what i do they're more
than basic obviously but that's covering
that the footwork
the first one like i said steps forward
a little tip the other side of the body
now if the person was advancing
you could open the back foot
still go to the middle
open the back foot step back
and the same applies please watch all
the details
perhaps i don't talk about but i do i'm
trying to time
my head to my toe with the turning of
the joe so everything's moving as well
forwards forwards
backwards
so
there's feet together
still across the line
feet together but this one slightly here
because
that's what you're doing you're patting
theirs away
on all the hasso's this part is the same
the feet are the same
the movement's the same because on all
hassles you go
you do this part first before the skis
or the rides
this is if they're skiing to the chest
what about the skis lower down
i've asked this question many times when
i used to go to america and they said no
this
there's only one hasso but
i've seen this so i'll show it
where it comes here not across the body
but it pats it away their lower strike
it pats it away that way
and then you gather it in
so here
we pat it away
you can do it the same as all of them
forwards
cut it away
feet together
or you can do the back foot
notice how my front foot on the back
foot one obviously slides and adjusts
okay
when they're down fast you don't really
see that there's two
to this one
or that one
this one or that one
one is low one is
high one is low
one is high
okay so all the points i can think of
for the
various uh hasso's that i do
i hope you can find a lot of time
putting in
there's many years of work there so
please enjoy
try them all keep going back looking at
them because
you'll miss lots of things that you
think you've absorbed
and keep looking at them and trying them
and see what ones you like you'll favor
some more than the other
thank you for your time don't worry
about master